come on king you're better than this
sando ah it's been a while bud
those stormy lighthouse books are doing
numbers man we should uh we should
collab or something king i'm i'm on it
but maybe our styles aren't the most
compatible you're talking about this is
gonna make so much money proving my
point steve look there's not such a
stretch between the two of us i mean all
your characters are depressed right now
just picture them on heroin what just
imagine sil but she's a stripper and a
single mom no imagine dalinar but he's a
recovering alcoholic who used to murder
people yeah that that actually happened
see we are perfect together brando okay
fine i guess we can try something out
let's let's start outlining yeah
outlining what what is that some kind of
nerd [ __ ] steven some of us need some
structure to our stories okay oh while
you were talking i wrote the first 50
pages of the book uh here i just sent it
to your email okay fine let me have a
look this is about a writer that is
having a call with someone called brian
silvers and is a total nerd am i brian
silvers it's [ __ ] good right
yes i guess but is this the beginning
like what what is this endings aren't
really my forte i was kind of hoping i
could write the series and then you
could just you know wrap everything up
at the end i'm done finishing other
people's series okay oh okay yeah cause
i gave george your number you did
okay i'll chat to you later about it
buddy love you
storms
oh my god he can talk
huh
still got it
[Music]